[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000.
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will be your driver
on this journey tonight i wanted to do
one out there
for the chess historians uh where i
cover some really interesting chess
games in it of themselves
but also these chess games have very
interesting stories behind them they
were very controversial
and there are still arguments to this
date about
many of them so uh most chess players
and even some non-chess players probably
know
that these world championship matches
can get a little bit crazy
in particular of course the bobby
fischer boris basket match of 1972
is probably the most famous chess match
ever played
and there were all sorts of crazy antics
bobby fischer making sort of ridiculous
demands getting forfeited for
a game and playing very badly in in the
second one
but tonight i'm not going to cover any
bobby fischer games because i feel like
those have been done to death
so hopefully you guys enjoy these other
controversial chess games
played in world championship world
championship matches throughout history
to start off with here i wanted to go
very very very old school
all the way back to the days of emmanuel
lasker
against carl schlechter of course these
two incredibly talented players at the
time
uh we're chess players yes but this
early on
in fact the players had different
professions as well chess was not big
enough really to make it a full career
even at the highest level
and this last game between the two in
their match is really interesting
because
actually lasker the defending champion
was down
a full point heading into the final game
of course by today's standards
schlechter would
only need a draw in order to secure
victory in the match
however as we'll see in the game
schlechter played
very very crazy chess very wild chess
risky chess
when perhaps if truly all he needed was
a draw
that wouldn't have been the case and
this has led to a ton of speculation
as to whether the match actually had
some very strange conditions where
schlechter perhaps needed to be up by
two points
in order to take the title so why don't
we go through the game
uh i will tell you there is no definite
answer to this people still speculate to
this day
and maybe after seeing the game you guys
in the chat will come to your own
conclusions whether or not you think
either schlecter just played a bad game
or if perhaps
he was motivated by this rule that he
needed
two points in order to win the match
let's jump into it here
lasker had the white pieces and started
with the move d4
we have d5 c4 and
c6 arriving at the slav and then just
a side note here i actually found this
game on uh
chess games that's where i usually just
search up my games
for these types of lectures and chess
games actually had some interesting
notes
by cappablanca and for those slav
players out there
capablanca officially has stated in the
notes of this game
that 2 e6 is better than the slav hate
to break it to you
capoblanca thinks e6 just better than c6
the more you know anyways the game
continued with knight f3
knight f6 e3 and then g6
and so this is the first interesting
decision uh in the opening
that i did want to mention so generally
slav players
do occasionally bring this bishop out to
g7
but it has to be with a very very
specific idea now
why is that and what is the idea
associated with
bishop g7 well i'm going to give you
guys in the chat room
a few moments to think about it and
we're going to go through the next few
moves which is just going to be normal
development
but while i go through these definitely
guys think about bishop g7
and what idea has to be connected with
it for this move to make sense
uh okay let's move on we have knight c3
bishop g7 the natural move
bishop d3 and kingside castles
now so far this is a pretty
theoretically normal position
this has been reached plenty of times
and white does tend to just castle
king's side
from here there are various ideas
including bishop g4
h3 for example and trading off these
guys
as well as taking on c4 as well as just
developing normally
but in this game lasker actually opts to
play this strange-looking move
queen to c2 rather than castles
and this is sort of
part of i think the argument as to why
perhaps this two-point rule
wasn't in effect because uh well later
in the game perhaps it looks as though
schlechter
is the one playing sort of wild and
crazy unnecessarily
which would suggest that he needed a
full point to take the title
lasker himself is also definitely
leaning into complications which
definitely suggests he was not going to
be happy with the draw either which is
what makes this game so interesting
uh schlechter continued with the
slightly strange looking
knight a6 and i don't hate this move at
all it's actually just aimed at knight
b4
very directly and this is going to be a
threat that white has to deal with
and now after a3 chat room i'm curious
if you guys have come up with the
key idea associated with bishop g7 now
is definitely the time
to play it for black and if he doesn't
find this move he is going to end up
just a little bit positionally worse as
we will see momentarily
so what idea has to be combined with
bishop g7
what do you guys think how do we
activate this bishop
on g7
i'll give you guys just a moment to
think
so yeah danilo in the chat is along the
right track you need to open up these
dark squares because if you let this
pawn sit on d4
the fact of the matter is this bishop is
going to be pretty useless in fact on g7
it's just going to be looking
at an incredibly solid incredibly strong
d4 pawn
and it's never really going to see any
activity so
yes occasionally you'll see black go for
ideas of e5
but especially with the way he's
developed his pieces here e5 is
definitely not
going to be so easy to achieve and for
that reason the correct move in this
position is actually to play the move c5
you counter attack like this using the
extra support of this knight on a6
and this is the manner in which black
can try and chip away
at this powerful d4 pawn and if black
doesn't find this idea
well then he'll essentially be playing
with a very very poor piece on g7
as we'll see later in the game in fact
selector does not play the move c5
instead opting for d takes c4
white of course recaptures and then
black plays the interesting idea of b5
and this is something that you'll
occasionally see in plenty of qgd
positions and some slob positions
black captures on c4 forcing white to
waste tempo
and then takes b5 with tempo as well
giving his bishop the b7
square white retreats back to d3
and now once again believe it or not
black's best try is to play the move c5
despite
this pawn on b5 being a little bit weak
after the idea of b5
black absolutely must rip open this
central diagonal and even more
importantly now
get rid of his pawn on c6 which is going
to be hampering his other bishop
as well understandably though schlecter
was not so ready to give up his b5 pawn
instead going for the move b4 uh of
course now the issue with this
is not actually the natural a takes b4
when you would get forked
but the move knight a4 and now c5 is
going to be
very very difficult to come by and
lasker definitely already has
a very solid opening advantage here
pawn takes c3 was played pawn takes a3
and now bishop b7
and once again really uh schlechter
perhaps in this game
being a bit too materialistic after
bishop b7
it's very clear that this bishop is just
a horrible horrible piece
if this pawn on c6 isn't removed and so
once again
c5 was going to be the right idea you
need to open up this diagonal and you
need to open up this diagonal as well
here in fact it is just a full pawn
sacrifice after takes
takes and takes but
we are now at the point in the game
where black would rather not have this
pawn on c6 at all
than keep the pawn and have it be in the
way of his own pieces
uh in the game though bishop b7 was
chosen and rook b1 is a very very nice
move
pressuring this bishop on b7 also
indirectly
pressuring the knight on a6 by
threatening to remove its defender
queen c7 is natural to defend the bishop
and defend against this threat
knight e5 is chosen another perfectly
natural move
to apply more pressure to c6
but once again black needs to take the
opportunity to play the move c5
before he sort of just gets gets crushed
in the game
knight h5 was chosen and now we see that
this bishop is sort of just desperately
trying to trade itself off for this
knight on e5 which
if you're familiar with the dark squared
bishop and the qgd or the slav
generally it can do a bit better than
trading itself off
for this night or at least it can force
it under more favorable
circumstances and now uh chat room once
again i wanted to ask you guys
what you think white should do how
should white respond to this idea of
knight h5
there's actually a variety of very
reasonable responses here
and i'm curious to see which one
the chat room is is leaning towards
what do you think
um the chess historians are are
definitely in the chat now
as well as the german speakers as well
as the german speakers
and my knowledge on schlecter's name is
quite limited
i do know that he was a doctor but again
i'm
a better chess player than chess
historian and i'm not actually that good
at chess
so that's saying something
so manny has my favorite idea in these
kinds of positions
it's clear that our opponent is aiming
to sort of capture on e5
and i want to sort of discourage this
idea so the move f4
is very natural very reasonable to me
now if bishop takes e5 wherever to be
played we could actually take back with
our choice of pawns and there is a
pretty
reasonable argument for taking back with
either but
it i do like just solidifying our center
here and no matter which pawn we
recapture with i like the fact that it
is supported from behind
by another pawn the f file might become
useful
or in the event that we capture like
this
the d4 square might be useful to us as
well
along with some ideas of opening up this
diagonal
completely in the game though lasker
chooses
another really interesting move of
course castling is perfectly fine for
white
and perhaps castling is just best along
with some ideas of f4 to follow
but lasker goes for the initiative with
the move g4
and this is a rather interesting idea
and i think this move once again
uh to talk about the actual
controversial points of this game
sort of hinted the fact that perhaps
lasker was really the one
uh pressing for victory in this match
perhaps at all costs moves like g4
certainly would suggest this whereas so
far black i think if anything has been
been playing more conservatively
despite what those uh you know those
sort of conspiracy theorists will call
them will say where
uh they describe schlechter as sort of
playing all out for a victory
in this game so far i think in the
opening especially schlechter chose a
fairly conservative approach
but okay after g4 and we do see bishop
takes e5
and now i think lasker makes a pretty
serious mistake i think
best here is to just take off this dark
squared bishop
again taking with the d pawn and after
knight g7 once again you have ideas
of f4 either immediately or following
kingside castles of course the spawn
cannot be captured immediately thanks to
the threat to the bishop
so something like castles followed by f4
and i think white has a very reasonable
advantage in the game though lasker
chose interestingly to take on
age five and his idea here was to just
totally
break down the light squares around the
uh the black king which is an
interesting idea
especially with this bishop sort of out
of play over here
on the b7 square but we'll see perhaps
it's not the most accurate
bishop back to g7 was played saving the
piece we have h takes
uh on g6 h takes on g6
and now the interesting move queen c4
by white and this of course is a move
that creates two threats
number one is taking advantage of the
pin on
the f pawn in front of black's king and
number two is actually the threat to
capture on b7
and capture on a6 to follow winning two
pieces for the rook which would be
a slight edge to white but once again
chat i'm
interested to see if you guys can
come up here come up with
a saving idea for black at this point
black
has had a pretty tough position uh to
this point in the game
with this bishop being so hemmed in and
this bishop not being
too useful but now was actually black's
chance
to try and at least equalize here so
what's the idea
what is the idea
okay if you guys at home don't have it
yet go ahead and pause the video
of course the idea is the same as it has
been for the past 20 moves
for black he has to play the move c5
opening up the bishop and chipping away
at the dark squares
now especially even though it may end up
costing black
again some material it's of the utmost
important to activate these bishops
before you know the the end comes around
black's king
so of course the move rook takes b7
wouldn't quite be working queen takes b7
is gaining a tempo on the rook but white
can start with the move rick g1
uh pressuring this g6 pawn and black
should play e6 to break the pin
and now after rook b7 queen b7 queen a6
queen a6 bishop a6 c takes d4
and it's true that white gets two pieces
for the rook in this case
but he also gets to break down this
white center and this white control
over the dark squares in the center
activating his remaining pieces
and there's plenty of open files for the
rooks to play on and i
honestly almost prefer to be black maybe
i would prefer to be black although it
is very very close here white with the
bishop pair
definitely has a lot of activity if he
can manage to coordinate
but once again schlechter was unwilling
to part with the material we'll say
even though materially i think just
point wise it would be even
after c5 unwilling to take this risk he
plays the move bishop c8 just defending
the bishop
from the threat of capture now of course
if the move bishop takes g6 were to be
played
uh schlechter has prepared this idea of
bishop g6
when he would be able to capture back on
g6 perhaps
for example queen takes a6 and f takes
g6
and even here uh schlechter would be
down upon
but he would have removed white's
powerful light squared bishop and he
would have left himself with the bishop
pair
and this position actually isn't too bad
for for black at all
in the game though lasker tried to
improve on this by playing the move
rook to g1 and now
once again i think it is in fact lasker
uh being the one who's taking a bit too
many risks here
uh of course rook g1 adds more pressure
to g6
but leaves behind this h2 pawn and black
here would have in fact been rewarded
for some bravery by taking on h2
because after rook takes g6 really it
looks scary
around the black king but with three
pieces not really participating in the
attack yet
black is going to be doing okay here you
might have to find
some critical moves like bishop to e6
and you might have to realize that after
scary stuff like this
king h8 your king is actually not
getting killed here
with black you have some very nice
pressure on this f-pawn in fact
and like i said these pieces not really
contributing
to the attack that's not to say that
white is like busted in this line it's
still going to be very very scary like i
said
but with counter play with this queen on
h2 that's sort of what black needed to
go for here
instead the move queen a5 check was
played and again
we see after queen a5 queen d5 schlecter
does seem to be playing a rather
conservative game and
this has been consistent so far through
the first 20 some moves i think
schlechter is in fact
despite what people say in my opinion i
think schlechter is very much
playing to survive this game not playing
necessarily to win
but playing to survive the game
continued with rook to c1
adding more pressure to the c6 pawn and
we see this bishop come back to b7 now
by schlecter and once again
the c6 pawn is the trouble for black
here
should have played c5 while he had the
chance and then should have played c5
even when he didn't have
didn't have the chance anymore you just
had play c5 to activate these pieces
queen c2 was alaska's choice setting up
for some bishop c4 threats
uh queen h5 to step out of these moves
uh and now it is in fact lasker who
initiates the sacrifice of material
uh and once again it's lasker who tries
to make the game more interesting
and tries to play the game for a win if
lasker were perhaps content with the
draw you might have seen something like
queen uh back to c4 even
when maybe black would play queen d5 and
we would have some kind of a draw now
that's sort of a stretch because black
can play
play better moves here but bishop takes
g6
was played by lasker and i think this is
not the move of a man
trying to draw this chess game i think
this is definitely
lasker not hoping for some kind of
perpetual but but hoping to find
checkmate
and we'll see that uh despite
this idea schlechter does manage to
survive the onslaught initially perhaps
better for lasker by the way rather than
bishop takes g6 immediately
might have been the tempo gaining queen
b3 hitting this bishop
on b7 and if
black for example were to try to defend
with something like bishop back to c8
while this pawn is hanging and this pawn
is hanging once again rook b8 would be
playable as well
but now rook takes g6 and
of course this bishop has no discoveries
with only these two retreating moves
available to it
and i do think white is pretty
significantly better here
the problem with the immediate bishop
takes g6 is uh
black or white might have a comfortable
position if f takes g
and queen b3 with check is allowed to be
played
but black does not necessarily have to
capture this bishop on g6 and in fact we
see the move
queen takes h2 come on the board gaining
time against this rook
on g1 not only gaining time but this
rook is actually
unable to step forward to a square leg
g3
because then of course after fg6 if you
try to repeat this line
look out because you're suddenly getting
checkmated on f2
so in order to make the sacrifice on g6
work white now has to play a very
awkward move
rook f1 this is not sort of the the
crushing attack that you hope for
when you play a move like bishop takes
g6 uh now black does in fact capture on
g6
white continues with this tactic queen
b3 check rick f7
queen takes b7 and now black suddenly
plays a good move rook a to f8
leaving this knight temporarily hanging
on a6
but getting pressure against the pawn on
f2
and in fact this does work out for black
if you were to try to capture on a6
rook takes f2 is just going to to end
the game
rather quickly rook f2 rook f2 for
example
and queen g1 is a fairly unstoppable
threat uh if you go queen c8
this is sort of the only way to stop it
i think of course though you leave this
bishop on d2 hanging
and the white king is not going to
survive the game
so rook af8 is a severe enough threat
that white cannot capture this knight
and instead queen b3 is played of course
pinning the rook to the king
king h8 is very natural by schlecter to
open up this rook's attacking
possibilities again
and lasker finds the only move f4 to uh
to stay in the game
anything else and black just comes
crashing through on the f-file
and now once again it does start to
appear that schlecter is playing some
very very active chess all of a sudden
but i think it's more out of necessity
than choice in this case
here schlechter plays the very natural
move g5 and if black doesn't start going
for things like g5
he'll start to feel like this knight on
a6 is very out of play
this bishop is sort of dead on g7 and
white would be able eventually
to reconfigure his king and his other
pieces
to be a bit more coordinated of course
black also playing with four isolated
pawns
uh end games are not really going to be
enviable here black has to sort of make
a push
for white's king so g5 was played
queen d3 is lasker's response
centralizing the queen defending the
rook
and sort of just solidifying the
position g takes f4
again very natural e takes f4 we see a
check by schlechter
king e2 a check by schlecter again and
now note that it is
not lasker who tries to repeat but in
fact
lasker is happy to play on with the move
rook f2
not accepting any kind of repetition
queen h5 check
rook f3 knight c7 so once again
uh it ends up being lasker in this case
the one
uh being the one who declines any kind
of repetition any kind of draw
and it's schlecter who might be
hoping to get out of the game with a rep
repetition
in this case after knight to c7 lasker
tried to snatch this pawn off on c6
this is something you'll see strong
players do throughout history and even
today
when they feel like they might be in a
bit of trouble you'll often see them
just sort of grab material like this and
say all right
i might be in trouble my king might be
weak but if i survive it
gosh darn it i'm going to be up a pawn
and then you'll have to
have to deal with that it just applies a
bit more pressure to the opponent in
many cases even psychologically
if not over the board knight b5 is
black's response this was his idea
to put pressure on d4 rook c4
and now rook takes f4 is the big
sacrifice
by schlechter and i think it's this move
that gets a lot of people thinking that
schlechter was very much playing for a
win
in this game but once again from my
analysis of the position
yes the sacrifice might not be necessary
but i also think
it was perhaps schlechter looking to
simplify the position you know
up to this point where 35 moves into the
game schlechter has been on the back
foot
for the majority of that and he's only
now starting to attack the white king
uh and just looking at the position you
know laskers has captured a pawn
lasker is currently up upon and i feel
like
in schlechter's shoes here that's a
tongue twister
you might start to think hey if i don't
attack this guy
i'm going to lose this end game pretty
horribly
in fact and i think that is a perfectly
reasonable justification of the move
rook takes f4
sacrificing the exchange but it
simplifies the position
quite a bit it gives black some very
very specific
difficult to meet threats uh right away
and it puts lasker definitely on the
defensive and perhaps schlechter was
thinking i don't know this for sure but
perhaps he was thinking
you know okay rook takes f4 and probably
there will be a perpetual
somewhere along the way uh in the game
though
after rook takes f4 bishop takes f4 is
played rook takes f4
the natural follow-up rook c8 check is
important
by lasker temporarily
uh discoordinating the black pieces by
drawing this bishop back
keeping the stroke sort of pinned up
even though this work itself is also
pinned and now king f2 by lasker is
is a fantastic move he unpins the stroke
applies pressure to the bishop on f8
and now schlecter has to find
some only moves in order to keep the
game in the balance queen h2 check was
correct
king to e1 and now unfortunately for
schlechter he gives
the wrong check queen h4 check would
have maintained the balance
when white has nothing better than to
start
repeating moves here check check check
check check
and the game might end in a draw
unfortunately though
for schlecter he chose queen h1 check
rather than queen h4
check and now of course white can
continue the game and play for a win
with the nice move rook f1 uh
escaping from any type of perpetual
check
and well yeah that's that's just the
main idea escaping from any kind of
perpetual check
queen h4 check was now played by
schlecter but it's too little too late
the king can now run to this side of the
board if queen h2 were to be played
the simple king d1 or king c1 are both
perfectly playable
when there are no more checks to this
king well sorry i guess you can give
queen h5 check but then after this there
are no more checks to the king
queen h6 isn't quite in time because
king b2
and the king can actually run to the
corner probably
king b3 would be a little ambitious with
knight takes d4 hanging but
to the corner where it will find safety
note that this line would not have
worked if queen h4 check
would be played here just to examine
if the king tries to step to d1 here
then after queen h1 of course rook f1 is
not playable
because black has an extra defender on
the f1 square
in the game though we see queen h2 queen
h1 the fatal mistake
now after queen h4 king d2 and white is
better
rick takes f1 queen takes f1 and the
pressure on this bishop is going to be a
bit too much
queen takes d4 now queen d3
queen f2 check king d1 knight d6
and rook c5
at this point of course the game is
still very complicated but i will say
from this point forward
white has an advantage and maintains
that advantage
throughout if black started trying to
check again of course
white would be able to eventually escape
these checks for example
king c2 knight d4 check king b2 queen g
queen f2 check we'll say although it's
queen f2 wrong for some reason
i don't know maybe king c3
knight d2 check king b4 and white
can run to the safety of these three
pieces which do an effective job of
covering his king
from most attacks uh in the game though
we saw
knight d6 rook c5 this bishop comes into
play
attacking the white king rook d5 king g8
knight to c5 the king runs up the board
bishop g7 now 96 and lasker starts to uh
to simplify the position
schlechter gives queen b2 check king a4
and now
after king f7 we do see the bishop come
off the board
and the play starts to approach
just a winning position for lasker of
course these types of end games are very
very difficult to play over the board
you're going to see a ton of mistakes in
these types of end games where both
kings are just so wildly open
with queens on the board but of course
white should always be preferred with
the major piece
against the knight in this case
queen b3 was lasker's choice setting up
some discovered check
possibilities kingy eights last year
gives another check
and snags upon queen a queen g4 check
queen d4
more checks the king runs back king a2
and lasker keeps his king safe and
slowly but surely uh
makes threats against the enemy uh king
this knight of course
was pinned queen c2 check now forces the
queens off the board
and this is a trivially trivially
winning end game
with the white king coming up the board
and schlechter resigns
the game here uh so all in all this
controversial game
was sort of the most surprising to me
you know i'd always heard of this game
as being you know sort of schlechter
going crazy
uh trying like these absurd things just
to avoid a draw but from my analysis i
i really do think it was just a case of
lasker being the one
seeking complications in schlecter if
anything
trying to play a bit too conservatively
that's the impression that i personally
got from the game
you're free to disagree with me on that
one but for my analysis
i think it's just a case of lasker uh
playing
very very well and what i think
was a must-win situation of course
that's up for debate
people still speculate to this day was
this two game rule in effect
two-point lead necessary for schlechter
to take the title
and my opinion is is probably not
judging from this chess game of course
there are probably historians out there
that know a lot more about the context
than me but from the chess game alone
i'm gonna have to side with alaska fans
on this one
and say i think he just played a good
game of chess
okay with that one out of the way i want
to move along
to another world championship match this
one happening
a lot more recently than uh lasker
schlechter
and that is a match between victor
korchnoy and anatoly karpov
so this match happened in 1978 actually
and it was only six years of course
after the famous bobby fischer boris
basket match with all the controversy
around it
all the organizer issues all of bobby's
complaints all spassky's complaints
and the 1978 match did not shape up
to be a smoother run than 1972.
of course at this time victor korchnoy
had recently
uh very publicly defected from the
soviet union
a union of course anatoly karpov was
still a part of
and there was definitely some bad blood
between the two players there was a lot
of controversy around it
a lot at stake especially for the soviet
government
they definitely didn't want to see
someone who had defected
winning the world chess championship
title and as a result of this you got
some really interesting characters
on each player's side there was all the
usual business of x-raying the chairs
and those types of complaints that were
quite simply ridiculous
but then also anatoly karpov had quite a
number of people in his
camp uh you know sort of supporting him
for the match of course
the players bring a ton of professional
chess players to help them mikhail tal
of course making an appearance
in support of karapov in this match but
also
karpov very famously had a
hypnotist on his team there was a
certified hypnotist
who was believed to have these sort of
mystical hypnotic powers
and as a result of this viktor korchnoy
actually showed up
to to a game wearing mirrored glasses
glasses to
reflect back any type of light or
perhaps
hypnotic stairs towards karpov
as a counter to this hypnotist being in
karpov's camp
so a ton of really interesting
controversy from the 70s in this one
korchnoy by the way also had some
characters in his camp
uh including uh there was a visit
to his villa during the match by two
uh americans who were actually out on
bail
for attempted murder at the time and the
organizers definitely had something to
say about that as well
but really really crazy stuff and if you
guys are ever interested i definitely
would recommend
researching and looking up a bit more on
this korchnoy karpov match because it
was
honestly incredible stuff what they were
both doing at the time
uh and one more bit of fun history for
you guys uh
during one of the matches very famously
uh someone from karpov's team came up
and gave karpov
a blueberry yogurt and of course victor
korchnoy's team
said that is ridiculous that was a coded
message
to help him in his chess game so if you
ever see anybody bring your opponent a
blueberry yogurt in your chess game
you are in good company if you accuse
them of cheating with victor korchner of
course being one of
chess's all-time legends anyways
enough of all that let's see what
actually happened in this chess game
uh here we have victor korchnoy with the
white pieces
and aside from all of the historical
context around this game
the match itself actually did shape up
to be a very exciting
uh you know contest of the sport uh
karpov took an early lead in the match
going up i believe four to one
quite early on then they had some draws
and eventually the score settled at
karpov with five wins
and korchnoy with two of course the
match format at this time was not
how we sort of know it today where they
play a total number of games and whoever
has the better score wins
uh the match at this time was of course
a first
to six wins match so karpov
up five to two uh with a ton of draws
needed only to win
one more game to win the match and
immediately after karpov achieved this
five to two score
korchnoy went on a bit of a tear and
we'll see
in this game he actually managed to
level the score
at five to five leading into the final
game
so let's see how korchnoy did it he
starts with the move
one c4 we see karpov reply with e6
knight c3 d5 and d4
and perhaps capoblanco would be a bit
happier with this development in this
game
than he was with the sloth that note
just makes me chuckle alright knight f6
c takes d5 e takes d5 sorry yeah bishop
g5
normal stuff bishop b7 e3 kingside
castles
uh bishop d3 knight bd7 and then we've
seen
white actually commit this knight to the
f3 square
occasionally you'll see white play the
move knight g to e2 these days
and play for some ideas of f3 but knight
f3 is perfectly reasonable as well
aiming for more solid control of the e5
square and sometimes to just plant a
knight
onto this square uh still though
very very normal stuff so far karpov
plays the move rookie eights
increasing his control of e4 uh queen c2
by white is normal increasing pressure
against a7
and central control we see c6 now by
black supporting the the center kingside
castles
knight f8 and then uh courtney actually
makes an interesting choice here he
plays the move
bishop takes f6 trading this bishop off
for a knight
and this is definitely not the most
normal trade
that you're likely used to seeing in
positions uh
like this generally in a lot of beginner
games you'll see a beginner bring out
the bishop to
g5 or b5 or you know respectively b4 g4
and just immediately trade off this
bishop for the night like like it's no
big deal you know even trades or even
trades what have i got to lose
of course in general this does tend to
be a very bad idea
why is it a very bad idea well because
you tend to actually increase
your opponent's activity by drawing this
bishop forward
and you're also trading off what could
be a useful bishop to contest your
opponent's good bishop
in exchange for a knight and a lot of
times you can do better for this bishop
you'll see black
sort of move this knight out of the way
and white can often trade off black's
good bishop for his you know
quote-unquote bad bishop despite it
being very active
so why does white in this case choose to
trade off these pieces here what do you
think chatroom
why does he do it
why does he do it
yes i'm i apologies for spoiling the
game but as brian in the chat says
it has been 42 years has been 42 years
so patrick says the dark square bishop
generally isn't great in the carlsbad
structure for black and i'm going to
have to disagree there
of course the carlsbad structure is the
structure we have on the board
where it's symmetrical aside from the
fact that white has an e3 pawn and black
has a c6 pawn of course you can get this
reversed
and it's very very similar and in these
structures of course
white's one of white's main plans is to
go for a minority attack
on the queen side of the board but
conversely this means that black's plans
do tend to be sort of on the king's side
uh and you'll often see black sort of
launching attacks
by use uh by the use of this dark
squared bishop so it can be useful
to uh not allow this bishop to go
uncontested
so of course here the ideas
for white are very very concrete and
very specific
and that's what you tend to see when
strong players
sort of break principles they usually
have a very concrete
very specific idea behind it and it
usually makes sense when you look at the
specific variations you'll see why it's
an exception to the rule
in this case of course first and
foremost this bishop
is not better on f6 than it was on e7
this bishop would much rather be on this
diagonal
or this diagonal where it can
effectively pressure the white king side
and hamper any minority attacks on the
white queen side as well
on f6 as we saw in the first game it's
sort of just staring at a d4
pawn aside from that of course
white is now by deflecting this bishop
gaining control of the b4 square and can
immediately play the move b4
and now his play on the queen side is
going to come with a bit more tempo
aside from that there is also the point
that knight e4
is often going to be an idea for black
in these positions
and by removing this knight he increases
his control
over the light squares by allowing this
bishop to remain
on this open diagonal without knight e4
ever being a possibility
to shut it out so bishop takes f6 still
not the most common move
but a very very intuitive move
sorry not intuitive but a very
reasonable move
when you take into account all of these
specific ideas that quarter noise has
so my word of warning to you is just
because you see a strong player do it
doesn't mean you should always repeat it
because
when you see a strong player break
principle they normally have
very very specific reasons as to why
they're doing it
and in this case quartz joint definitely
does so bishop takes f6 and now b4
black responds by playing bishop to g4
trying to activate his
final piece and remove this knight
with you know of course some threats of
fracturing the white pawns
white plays the natural move knight to
d2
as far as weakening h7 i don't know if
that's as relevant as those other
uh reasons i just mentioned of course
black did just play the move knight f8
uh and h7 is is going to be defended
well enough but
that's another point to mention h7 is a
bit weaker
although white's ideas really are not
going to be to checkmate black on the
king's side it's going to be for queen
side play here
anyways in the game rook to c8 is a
natural move
improving the rook and preparing to
fight against any
b5 pushes but with the move c5 when all
of a sudden
the bishop on f6 is starting to make a
lot more sense
right so with b5 sort of uh
hampered now white makes another really
interesting decision
he plays the move bishop f5 he's trading
off
this bishop for this bishop now why
would white
ever want to do this well the fact of
the matter is
white is now going for a total clamp on
the
dark squares uh on the black queen side
he's no longer interested in playing the
move b5
uh where this bishop would be quite
useful perhaps
to attack you know a weak d5 pawn if
this pawn ever moves
uh to step to this diagonal to to uh
attack
the black pieces that's no longer
white's idea
after this move rook c8 he wants to shut
this bishop out of the game
by playing against it on the dark
squares which is a really interesting
idea
and so this bishop is really of no use
to korchnoy in this plan
so he plays bishop f5 to trade it off
and we'll see
a lot more specifics on how this plane
works out as we go here bishop takes f5
queen takes f5
and now queen d7 by karpov of course
karpov with the black pieces up five to
four in the match
probably okay with trading down into a
simpler position
you know just wanting to get the white
pieces and wanting his shot
at victory queen takes d7 is played
knight takes d7
and now the lack of space for black
might be felt a bit less with queens off
the board
of course the only natural follow-up to
this idea is a4 for white
when now if black tries something crazy
like a5
white again is not really going to go
for b5 which might seem normal
but he can get away with taking on a5
and then targeting the b7 pawn
so a5 not really playable which means
after a normal move
like bishop e7 rook b1 knight f6
there's nothing to stop white from
achieving his clamp on the dark squares
with the move a5 and from here i think
this is just going to be a very very
pleasant
position for white and karpov is going
to have to work very very hard not to
lose this game i think black is already
in pretty serious danger that being said
with black what would you guys in the
chat room
think to do to try and stay in this game
any ideas to try to stay in this game
with black there are a couple of
resources
that you might find pretty interesting
here
what to do with black to stay in this
game
why trade queens well in this case both
sides had the reason to trade queens
andrew uh
black perhaps i'm speculating here but
maybe black
liked his chances to draw a bit better
in the end game than with pieces on the
board black of course had less space
and when you do have less space it
becomes it can become easier to use
the space that you do have with less
pieces on the board
in the meantime uh white's queen again
really wasn't going to do much to
contribute to his lock on the dark
squares just like the light squared
bishop
white's not going for any type of mating
attack in this position his plays on the
queen side
and so why not trade queens sort of
becomes the answer for
for both sides
so those of you suggesting a6 are
playing like karpov
but i actually don't like this uh
practically
for black it's not necessarily an awful
move it's not the losing move
but practically if you play the move a6
you are giving up on your dark squares
uh essentially forever uh this b7 pawn
is always going to be a bit of a
weakness if a knight lands on c5
you're never going to be happy capturing
it when you open the b
file for white's rooks and you're never
going to be happy uh
you know committing an entire piece to
the sole defense of the b7 pawn
and this is actually what karpov went
for in the game but again i don't think
practically this is going to give black
the best chances of holding on
believe it or not here there's a really
cool idea of playing the move b5
and while objectively
this is still going to be a very tough
position for black to hold
i think it does intuitively make sense
to try and clarify the position as
quickly as possible
the key line to calculate is a takes b6
a takes b6
when after rook a6
black can perhaps consider playing the
move c5
trying to open things up for his bishop
even more just trying to break free of
this clamp on the dark squares
alternatively you can also consider the
move
b5 here as well and what's the idea
for black in this position well the idea
is if you can hold on to the c6 pawn for
a few turns
and get your knight to a square like c4
c6 is going to be the only weakness in
the position
and it's not the easiest weakness for
white to attack that being said i do
think white has a
an advantage here but b5 is always an
idea you should sort of consider
and of course if white does not take on
b6 if you play some type of waiting move
let's say h3
now perhaps a six by black
and while if you ask any computer it's
going to give
a pretty significant edge to white it's
not going to be easy to win anymore
because now all of a sudden your pieces
have no way to invade
and c6 is the only weakness now this is
sort of
more a matter of opinion than a matter
of objective evaluation either way black
is going to have not the
most comfortable position but i do think
this idea of b5
might practically be a bit easier for
for black to handle
with the weakness on c6 rather than on
b7
with all that in mind though karpov did
go for a6 and we'll see
how he dealt with the weakness on b7
white wasted no time immediately
bringing this knight to c5
no reason not to rookie 7 is black's
choice for defense
we see king f1 bringing the king to the
center 98s
king e2 knight d6 king d3
and once again we have this type of
position where white has a total clamp
on the queen side
and can sort of improve his pieces as at
his leisure here
bringing the king all the way into the
center and after rook c
to e8 now your goal with white is to
find some way
to press your advantage for more
so with the white pieces here say you
are viktor
korchnoy how can you try to press this
game
for a win
how can you press this game for a win
a z says double rooks on the c file
so yeah black actually does get this
knight to d6 which looks like it's in
good position to control b7
and to at least keep in mind some active
hops as well
but we'll see it is still white with all
the play
see danilo once again has the right idea
uh you're not gonna make much progress
opening up the queen's side and the
reason for that
is as someone in the chat has mentioned
he has locked down the white squares
even when white has locked down the dark
squares
so it's difficult to play a move like b5
in this position of course it's
difficult to
do it with any you know meaningful
threats so
now is the time for coach knight to
switch ideas and go back to the center
with these ideas of playing f3 or just
e4 directly f3 and e4 or e4
without f3 and this is a very common
idea
to press for a win in end games like
this
when things are so so closed and you
have rooks on the board
it's going to be very difficult to make
any progress to invade with any of your
pieces
unless you open up at least one avenue
for those pieces in the game and so
we'll see now
quartz joy completely switches sides of
the board he has
done what he's set out to do on the
queen side locking down this weakness on
b7
when black really has no counter
weakness to attack
and now he switches to the center in
order to open up
a file for his rooks immediately he
plays rookie 1
g6 by black and now rookie 2. g6f6 is
the defensive setup
that black tries just trying to control
these squares on the fourth rank
white of course doubles up and once
again you'll see
black is sort of without active ideas
here so bishop h6
and black is slowly trying to improve
his structure and prove his pieces
but white is sort of under no pressure
and can continue this attack
at his own pace so knight d to b3 was
played
bishop back to f8 knight d2 bishop h6
always repeats uh h3 now gets played
king f7 and white improves the structure
even more with the move g4
after bishop f8 we actually see the move
g3 or f3
and white now is fighting for some light
squares on the king side
taking away hops from the knight a good
idea in any position middle game
end game or otherwise just taking away
the knights forward
moves and then we see after rook d8
knight d3
knight b5 rook f1 bishop h6
uh white continues pressing with the
move f4
uh which might not be what you guys
expected but uh korchnoy is just trying
to take
as much space as he can before he
decides to open
up the position with e4 uh bishop f8 now
comes on the board we see knight back to
d2 knight back to d6 we're back to e1
h6 work back to f1 just some waiting
moves here nothing too special
rook b8 rook a1 rookie 8 rookie one rook
b8
and now finally court snoy opens the
position with the move e4
this had to be done at some point for
white to try to win the game
and chord joint decided now was the
correct time
d takes e4 with check of course is
played knight d takes e4
knight b5 and now knight c3 one pair of
rooks comes off the board
and now black decides to take off the
knight for the bishop as well
and plays the move rook d8 so
chat room let's see
if you can find white to move and
play for an advantage here white to move
and play
for an advantage i guess this move isn't
so hard to find because it's sort of an
only move
sort of an only move here
so of course the move i'm talking about
is going to be the move knight takes b5
no other move really to defend the
d-pawn
but we'll see that it is going to be
white playing for an advantage in this
endgame
the reason for that is all down to the
position of
the kings white's king is active and
centralized
and black's king is not in order to keep
it that way
quartz knight plays a very accurate move
here and that is the move
f5 removing any active ideas
for this king creating sort of this wall
on the sixth rank that the black king
cannot
penetrate through as well as this
covering squares in the e file
g takes f5 was played g takes f5
and now black tries for activity through
rook
to g8 and so once again chat room
let's see if you can uh let's see if you
can find out
how to uh press this position for an
advantage
with uh with white
so yeah the the chat is is asking about
e4 white's going for e4 in order to
create more weaknesses
not necessarily white is going for e4
not because it you know creates a ton of
weaknesses for black
but it gives his pieces an avenue into
the position right his pieces were sort
of trapped behind his own pawns
in behind enemy pawns and so with e4 he
opens up the position enough
to induce some trades and start fighting
for more
so uh some guesses are coming in here
rookie 3 is actually not going to be the
answer in this case
after rookie 3 you might get hit with
rook a8 and you might find
this a pawn is not the killer that you
want it to be
so those of you pl saying king c3 are
playing like quartz noi
unfortunately for you korchnoy did not
play
the uh most accurate move
in this position king c3 though is a
very interesting try and we'll see how
it worked out for court joy
i think perhaps best would be either the
move rook e6
or rook a2 with a very similar idea the
idea is to go
after this c6 pawn for uh
for black for example ricky six
rook g3 check king e4 takes and then the
key move here
is going to be the move d5 what's the
point of d5 well the point is you better
be very very careful
about capturing this guy king d4 for
example we don't actually care so much
about the d5 pawn
rook h1 and now there are some ideas of
c6 creating past pawn but in this case
after rook h1
rick b6 is best when all of the black
pawns on the queen side fall
and white is left with two uh two past
pawns
on the a file and the c file uh
rook a2 again has a similar idea
of rook g3 check king e4
takes and the move a6 when now after
takes takes c6 is going to be weak and
again white is going to end up
with a couple past pawns chord joy in
the game though
does go king c3 and the idea now after
something like
g3 was to bring the king up to b4 karpov
perhaps a little bit afraid of this goes
for rook e8
offering up a trade of the rooks now as
we are a bit short on time i will not
ask you to totally calculate out this
king and ponden game i think it should
be a draw from what i could tell but
still complicated stuff instead quarter
just keeps the rook on the board with
the move rook d2
which is perfectly reasonable rook e4
now
was karpov's attempt at uh finding
counter play
king b4 is natural bringing the king to
the queen side and after king to e8
of course now what is the winning idea
for white
last question for you guys chad what is
white's
idea to try to win the game i said
winning idea it's not necessarily a
winning position yet
for white but this is sort of the only
attempt left for white to play for an
advantage
only way left for white to play for the
advantage
of course i am talking about the move
pawn to a6 uh
sacrificing this a pawn in an attempt to
give your king a root into the position
where it can actively uh try and
escort its own pawns to the end of the
board
spawn of more suppose of course must be
captured with uh b takes a6
and now after king a5 king d7 don't make
the mistake of capturing this guy
you're not interested in the a pawn
you're interested in making your c
pawn a queen which means king b6 is the
better move
karpov now played accurately for some
time b4
is the only idea for black to stay in
this game you have to sort of race
white to the edge of the board white
pushing a c pawn and black pushing a b
pawn b4 is the only way to do it now of
course
d5 is the breakthrough tactic that white
needed
we see cd5 and now rather than
c6 which would allow the king to come to
d6 and the rick to come behind the pawn
we see rick takes d5 first king of c8s
and now rook d3 to keep an eye on
black's b-pawn
and keep everything sort of locked down
and now
finally karpov does start to slip he
needed to play the move
rook c4 i believe to stay behind white's
past pawn
and instead he pushes a5 which of course
looks very natural but allows white to
start playing for the advantage
with the killer move rook g3 and
now you can sort of apply the same
principles uh
that you apply in a pure rook and pawn
versus rook end game
the white king has gotten to the sixth
rank the black rook cannot check from
behind and
c6 is going to be sort of a devastating
threat here
with checkmate to follow or in fact
we'll see a different threat
be just as devastating for black to deal
with
in the game uh
in the game karpov tries the move b3
which is sort of a vain attempt to get
the rook
to come back to take on b3 when rook
before check would be a nice little
sneaky victory by karpov but rook g8
check
uh instead was not played sorry but
rather king c6
is the only winning move by viktor
korchnoy forcing the king out from in
front of the pawn
uh otherwise checkmate will be played of
course if rookie eights then this is
just a free pawn
so king b8 was tried now white can
capture this one with
check king to a7 and now the white
the black king gets further evicted by
some rook checks we see the king get out
of the way of the pawn and with black's
b-pawn now
uh fallen black does not have any
counter play and the white c
pawn will be victorious in the game
a4 is played white snaps off another f
pawn
rick f4 white snaps off an h pawn and
after a3
we see check and takes and after rook
takes f5
of course this end game is just
completely losing
down two pawns for karpov after rook g3
rook f6 or g8 check king c8 sorry king
c7
czech king c8 rick h7
keeping an eye on this pawn and
preparing to push it all the way up the
board
while keeping the threat of the sea pawn
of course black went ahead and
resigned in this position uh of course
there's just simply nothing to be done
for karpov and so with this game victor
korchnoy leveled the match at five to
five
however it was not meant to be of course
this was game
31 in the match when quarterly won and
unfortunately for him that it was all
over
by game 32 karpov coming back in the
very next game
with a victory to end the match before
any more controversy could happen
perhaps the blueberry yogurt was
victorious after all
hopefully you guys enjoyed this uh
edition of the road to 2000 where i went
over
a little bit more of chess history i
know we spent a long time on each of
these games but there was a lot to talk
about
and of course a lot of contacts to
provide as well
if you liked it i might do a part two
with some more controversial games
just just let me know what you guys
thought as always
if you're watching live we do have the
end game class coming up right after
this where i'm going to show you how to
fight for the win
with even material uh usually by having
some kind of space advantage
if you're watching the video version and
that's it for you you're all chessed out
thank you so much for joining me
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you
next time
you